Першокласники вчаться читати й писати.
Поки вони ще використовують кирилицю на уроках казахської мови,
але вже незабаром і ця школа в селі Кайназар перейде на латинську абетку.
Запроваджують нову систему поетапно.
Перехід на латиницю по всій країні має відбутися до 2025 року.
Спершу вчителі пройдуть курси підвищення кваліфікації.
- Для нас, учителів, це буде складніше, тому що
ми звикли до іншої абетки.
А діти - вони ж молоде покоління і швидко все засвоюють.
- Батьки не зможуть допомогти нам із переходом на латиницю,
бо вони самі ще не навчені. Виходить, діти будуть
займатися лише у школі. Тому ми переживаємо, що
навантаження ляже переважно на вчителів.
Перехід на латиницю стосується тільки казахської - це державна мова в країні.
Хоча багато казахів досі говорять російською так само добре, як і казахською.
Більшість жителів Казахстану, зокрема діти, - двомовні.
Російську мову вивчають і у школах,
тож школярам доведеться освоїти новий алфавіт.
В Алма-Аті вже можна побачити вивіски латинським шрифтом.
Незабаром у цьому місті та й по всій країні
потрібно буде замінити дорожні знаки,
перевести на латиницю офіційні документи,
періодичні видання та підручники.
- Перехід із кирилиці на латинський алфавіт
має символізувати розрив Казахстану з радянським минулим.
Це допоможе країні віднайти національну ідентичність,
тож влада інвестує мільйони в цей процес.
Деякі сусідні держави в Центральній Азії
перейшли на латиницю одразу після розпаду Радянського Союзу.
Водночас багато казахів критично налаштовані до нового алфавіту.
- В Узбекистані давно вже на це перейшли.
Ми, ймовірно, як країна, яка намагається не відставати від Заходу,
від Європи, теж будемо.
Але єдине - це стане ударом по бюджету.
- Нічого не дає. Плюсів, за великим рахунком, жодних.
Навіщо це потрібно? Не знаю.
Можливо, майбутнє покоління скаже, що це потрібно було.
- Мені, приміром, не дуже так складно, тому що
ми вже і так в інтернеті так спілкуємось, тому все нормально.
Багато людей старшого покоління досі не знайомі з латинським алфавітом,
однак 8-класники з Кайзанара кажуть, що вони
давно освоїли "західні" літери і використовують їх для спілкування в соцмережах.
Із переходом на латиницю уряд Казахстану пов'язує
великі надії: нова абетка зробить країну сучаснішою,
а нове покоління казахів - більш відкритим до світу.